hello one and all this is adam from
playstation grenade
i wanted to show you a cool little
easter egg we found whilst playing deus
ex mankind divided
during your visit to prague look out for
an antique shop appropriately named
future past antiquey when you enter
don't worry about the store clerk just
bypass him and run down into the
basement
it may look like a mess but it is in
fact a veritable treasure trove
just around the corner left sitting in
all the dust is the companion cube from
portal
i don't know about you but this is
absolutely mind-blowing i love this
little nod to
the portal series but it doesn't stop
there
because in this basement are four other
games just waiting to be discovered
over on the book table is a copy of soul
reaver from 1999
just underneath that on the floor is in
fact a copy of tomb raider legend from
2006
and the goodies continue as over to the
right is a copy of hitman codename 47
which was released in 2000 the last
video game easter egg is found in the
storage crate at the back of the room
once you've shifted a few cardboard
boxes you are greeted by a copy of deus
ex human revolution which is the
predecessor to mankind divided
so have you found any other easter eggs
whilst playing deus ex let us know below
if it's not too much to ask please give
us a like and subscribe for more easter
eggs
this is playstation grenade we'll see
you next time